i'm so excited for this
jordan james my hero come on up here
please
[Music]
thank you thank you so
much for first of all coming on this
show okay so good deeds buffalo
now
how
did you do this and i'm sorry but mad
respect to you getting a show on
broadcast television it's not easy i
can't believe your marymore is saying
this to me it's hard it is it's been so
challenging but
buffalo western new york the community
has been so
wonderful they have jumped on board and
have been so supportive
and i think with with my determination
they weren't going to say no
it just wasn't going to happen and
you're somebody
you're somebody who inspires me to be
myself because you've always been
unapologetically drew barrymore and that
is something that i aim to be like thank
you so much to that
um
for me it's about
looking back at those dark days of being
in high school and being bullied and
those other kids and their stories
i want to be able to do it for them
because they probably didn't feel like
they could do it and so here i am
and you are
how do you approach the content of your
show
so for anything that we do on the show
it has to come from the heart when i get
the nominations i research these folks
and i really get to know their story and
if it doesn't resonate with me if it
doesn't give me the chills we don't do
it but i'll tell you everybody so far
that i've been buffalo is a beautiful
place we truly are the city of good
neighbors
and i think
those you know those are what keep me
going those people it's funny too
because um
meeting people that you didn't know
before right now
this is crazy
you're sorry to interrupt are you
kidding do it
well we have a banter going i love it
this job makes me happy does it make you
happy it absolutely does i think
it absolutely does um
kindness being kind is like the only
thing you can give but you don't run out
of
and being able to do this job i get to
be kind to which i am
and i get to magnify it it's such a
beautiful thing i am so thankful can i
ask like
um you have been through a lot in your
life
do you think it was part of the
road to being an empathic person
i truly believe so and thank you for
acknowledging that i'm empathic because
i've felt that i am very empathic in my
life
and i think with my mom's passing in in
2019
um
i made the decision to donate her organs
and three months later
um i received a letter in the mail from
a gentleman who received her corneas
and when i got that message
but um
it filled me with joy to know that
somebody would be able to see again
and be able to vision and see the life
that my mom once saw
and i think that's what really pushed me
to want to learn more about these
stories because there's so many out
there
and is it true also that you
i'm like
um is it true also that um through being
an organizer of um blood donations that
you've also like have the data on the
fact that 800 lives have been affected
through the blood drives like 800 lives
have been saved because of your blood
drives yes thank you
it's
it's sometimes hard to comprehend that i
did this but it's so beautiful and i
think when i get to share that story
with people and they feel that they can
do something that's what i do it all for
to spark that motivation to do what
they've wanted to do is it true that
like you haven't um been able to get
some like
suits for the show and you would like to
get some suits for the show yes so
because we launched the mill pandemic
our sponsors pay directly for production
there's no money in it for me but it's
not about that it's about their stories
so we've been able to do this show um in
eight months we did 13 episodes
and all of the money is basically just
covering the cost covering just cost
extra those extras so i've never been
able to own a suit in my life or
or clothes you would wear on television
right
so i decided to go to the salvation army
here we are
well there is this wonderful company
called indochino and they're a custom
suiting and apparel company
um and so they're gonna give you twenty
five hundred dollars to make some custom
for you
suits
i don't know how to
thank you so much well also like
i like the idea of something being made
specifically for you yes to have
something for myself
well and you'll be doing it in style
[Music]
you